et salut à tous et bonjour à toi stouf
bonjour à tous salut Fatou j'espère que
tu vas bien
j'espère que toi tu vas bien
merci de le demander hein
toujours de beaucoup de plaisir dans
cette parole Fatou
donc on va couvrir aujourd'hui le match
des
attendez
ils ont un nom bizarre évidemment et oui
d'ailleurs les les Saint-Louis Ark
Bishop c'est ça contre les Indiens mgd1
donc j'espère que ça veut dire mgdr on
m'a demandé en live ce que ça voulait
dire je voulais pas capable de répondre
à cette question
voilà donc le match
j'espère que ça veut dire
en tous les cas donc le match va
commencer on vient on vient de voir la
fin du match de l'équipe française Blitz
contre les Chinois ça a été très très
difficile pour les français et chinois
qui sont vraiment très très solides et
donc là on va voir un peu ce qui se
passe donc dans ce match je passe ta vie
un petit peu les équipes Fatou où est-ce
que tu veux que je que je parle un petit
peu des des forces en présence
j'ai vu mais j'aime beaucoup t'entendre
parler donc n'hésite pas je comprends
bien alors je vais vous montrer regardez
là vous allez avoir
hop arrêt sur image donc ça c'est voilà
les compos d'équipe karwana donc ça
c'est toutes les forces qui peuvent y
avoir dans l'équipe après je vais vous
montrer un peu qui joue et qui ne joue
pas vous allez voir aussi les Indiens
c'est pareil il regazi qui joue il y
aura Tabata bike etc donc par rapport
aux joueurs que vous allez voir dans ce
match là on va avoir en première table
toucher les Américains
rien que le l'ancien numéro 2 mondial
carvana qui va rentrer en lice dans ce
championnat ok on aura aussi un jeune
Grec qui est qui est assez fort et
surtout en glitter rapide c'est le jeune
Théodore
ensuite on va voir le jeu par
l'expérience
à combien de qui a un joueur
arméno-américain dire
qui qui a 2600 depuis
très très longtemps
et au quatrième checker du coup c'est
une jeune américaine
ou qui a 2300 et lots alors que chez les
Indiens on va avoir du GO 1er échec qui
est regazi donc n'est plus à présenter
maintenant qui est qui est la jeunesse
qui progresse tous les jours un petit
peu et qui a envie de faire rapide c'est
vraiment un des meilleurs joueurs du
circuit donc donc un peu ce qui nous
fait on aura le numéro de tabac à Beille
donc tabac Tabe c'est un genre iranien
qui doit être peut-être maintenant après
la après la
le départ de Firouz Jacques maintenant
numéro 2 je pense son pays donc tabataba
26 50 quand même à peu près
ensuite on va avoir en tant que féminine
chez chez les Indiens du coup c'est
harica donc un numéro 1 indienne qui est
quasiment 2600 et là aussi et en 4e on
aura un jeune grand maître qui a à peu
près 15 16 ans ça se voit la caméra on
le voit ici qui boit dans sa petite
bouteille rose on dirait ça tout
et bah du coup mital du coup qui est
jeune grand-mère
donc là il va je prends la partie contre
carwan alors qu'il aura les pièces
noires contre karwana donc j'attends
encore un petit peu de voir si les
appariement enfin s'il est parti
au moins ce qui se mettent en place là
vous voyez qu'il y a encore la partie
mais c'était de
asun Bacro contre Louis pink que vous
avez sous les yeux mais du coup à pas
voir ça on va passer sur un autre match
mais tant que j'ai pas de partie je ne
peux pas
je ne peux pas passer dessus donc
patience patience est-ce que tu as un
favori Fatou pour ce petit match
[Musique]
alors alors est-ce que tu as ton nom que
je prenne l'opposition oui
non je pense qu'ils sont plus forts
donc
on peut rien y faire alors j'ai j'ai eu
le plaisir et l'honneur de de faire
équipe en Top 12 avec tabac abeilles
d'ailleurs qui est un genre extrêmement
sympathique et donc du coup bah moi je
vais le je vais le je vais le supporter
j'ai pas encore fait équipe avec Kawana
pas encore peut-être bientôt mais du
coup je supporterai pas pour aujourd'hui
et du coup du coup non mais ça match
assez équilibré mais c'est vrai que
irrigazi par exemple il avait sorti
carvana lors du speechess cette année
donc déjà bon ça c'est de plus fort
ensuite derrière tu as quand même tu as
le numéro 1 indienne qui quasiment 2100
et l'eau donc je vous rappelle en fait
par rapport par rapport aux tiens ça y
est on va voir la partie qui monte en
français
par rapport aux compositions il faut
avoir une moyenne vélo à 25 50 sachant
que les joueurs à plus de 2700 hello
compte comme un 2700 hello et que les
joueuses à plus de 2350 comptent comme
un 2350 ce qui veut dire que Arica qui a
2550 à peu près son vélo et ben elle
compte comme un 2350 donc c'est un peu
de cheaté par rapport à la moyenne parce
que du coup ben tu vois par exemple les
américains ils ont mis le paquet en haut
ils ont eu plein de joueurs à 2006 2007
devant par contre ils ont ils ont une
féminine à 2300 hello donc 2300 hello
c'est
c'est bon elle va avoir du mal hein
parce que là je vais prendre des joueurs
à 2005-2006 donc c'est quasiment j'ai
pas envie de dire c'est pour assurer
mais c'est déjà pas mal pour pour les
Indiens par contre les Indiens sont
moins forts au milieu tu vois
mais bon après faut voir parce que un
Rica 2006 mital 2005 bon avoir en tout
cas ça a commencé dans carwana du coup
qui a des
Noirs j'avais raison non mais j'avais
raison je suis ingénieur en fait je suis
un génie
parce que j'avais tout fait à la main
et j'avais tout fait à la main
d'ailleurs je te le montrer dans une
petite seconde juste un verset du coup
les caméras
afficher le tableau à droite c'est
possible aussi
oui mais ça malheureusement c'est pas
moi qui le fait c'est chascom tu sais ok
et du coup je ne peux pas du tout
j'ai pas la main dessus qui va le faire
tout seul
mais juste pour te pour t'expliquer un
petit peu
[Musique]
j'avais demandé les appareils
aujourd'hui on me les a donné un peu
tard et du coup comme ça donner et ben
j'avais déjà trouvé apparemment enfin
j'avais j'avais on va dire
[Musique]
je l'avais fait tout seul j'ai eu un
tableau qui disait B11
je me suis trompé j'ai tout mélanger et
là on voit en fait que non je peux pas
mélanger regarder
moi j'ai bien écrit
j'avais écrit mital carwana tu as vu
Henri Ivo de rouge avec écrit
figure-toi que c'est quand toi qu'après
j'ai reçu une photo avec les appareils
non et que sur la photo que j'ai reçu
tout est inversée les couleurs sont
inversées je me suis dit tiens
j'ai fait une erreur je dis bon d'accord
du coup j'ai fait confiance à la à la
photo comment envoyer mais moi j'avais
raison du coup ben t'inquiète pas
j'étais pris de cours mais j'ai toujours
les appareils manches je suis prêt donc
je vais quand même changer les autres
tapes parce que du coup j'avais tout
changé tu sais donc j'imagine que du
coup ça tableau deux ça fait un ça fait
un
[Musique]
verset tout du coup avec un du coup qui
a les
attends table 1 c'est Mittal qui est
bien d'accord ok donc ça c'est des
blancs du coup tableau 2
bienvenue salut
c'est parce qu'il y a autant de
U dans nos
c'est comme ça faut bien tous les
prononcer
en tout cas on est bon chez nous pour
l'instant alors ça c'est Nolan
comme ça
j'ai déjà vu
d'ailleurs il y a une vente marrante il
me semble que c'est bien là il faut
prendre ici d'un point de 6 D4 CD
cavaliers prank cavalier prend d'un
point et il me semble si je dis pas de
bêtises
que c'est tour des 8 et 4
et ça c'est gros avantage noir c'est une
partie comme ça que j'avais joué à Créon
et en fait ça me permet de pouvoir je
suis sur le 7 alors chez Madame
parce qu'en fait ça donne du temps en
blanc
[Musique]
j'enlève ce fou et puis c'est pas si
c'est pas si clair rajoute des 4 est-ce
qu'il va se passer ce qu'on a dit ce
serait incroyable
10 + 2 la cadence
donc salut à tous hein
salut à tous
il a plein de
rien
pas de toons
[Musique]
à l'époque où tu as acheté quand j'avais
16 ans dans peut-être 18 ans c'est un
truc en espagnol que j'avais acheté à
Santiago des composés là donc ça va de
Compostelle c'était le jour où j'ai lu
que l'alcool était semble était
dangereux pour la santé et ben j'ai
arrêté de lire voilà donc du coup du
coup toi je suis le plus depuis 18 ans
du coup ah oui non j'ai 18 ans c'est
fini ouais alors fouet
sur D4 on prend
celle-ci explique cela
c'est ça c'est ça
oui t'inquiète j'ai l'habitude est-ce
que tu veux qu'on aille voir du coup ce
qui se passe ailleurs pas tout
ouais on va la voir un petit peu ce qui
se passe du coup alors attends
laisse-moi faire les choses bien du coup
ici on va vous mettre
fait ça ça à chaque fois que je dois
changer de scène
je change le nom des joueurs
du coup je peux passer à la scène de
maintenant avec la deuxième partie on a
ici Arika
contre
[Musique]
on avait la position plus ou moins je
crois qu'on fait n'importe quoi
oui
on l'a déjà vu du coup donc à combien
ici avec les Blancs contre tabac Tabe
donc en haut on va du coup je vais vous
mettre
les nouveaux des joueurs
[Musique]
à Cobian ok donc ça c'est une position
c'est la composition ça c'est une c'est
une sorte de candidat ici
donc
c'est normal j'ai envie de dire ca va
aller prendre cavalier prend à combien
qui qui se prend pas trop la tête est-ce
qu'un jour regarde ce sera possible un
poisson donc je pense
et puis on a 4 qui par exemple
B3 empêche B4 qui a toujours la prise en
passant
j'ai du mal à trouver tu as même le
chemin
j'ai du mal à trouver le chemin tu vois
j'ai pas accès à la case A4 sur le 4
souvent dans ses positions avec les
Blancs et ben là ce qu'on appelle
l'attaque de minorité enfin tout tu dois
connaître je pense tu as déjà vu ses
idées
en fait en gros mais une tour en C1 on
joue B4 donc en le pion il par exemple
en 7 on joue B4 B5 pour échanger les
pions en fait taper après sur ce pion
c'est 6 ce qui sera arriéré et donc là
du coup avec le pion à 4 j'ai du mal
après elle est quand même trois qui est
intéressant parce qu'au final après V3
ben après la prise je vais avoir la
colonne ouvertes et taper aussi sur
l'option
c'est la direction de prendre la
position blanche en fait d'aller vers ce
côté d'aller taper sur B sur ces faire
quelque chose
alors tout reprend j'aime pas trop il y
avait le C4
avec des ressources un coup comme B5 qui
peut bien tenir la position bien bloqué
et bloquer un truc qui va être arriéré
tu vois
même si bon il y a toujours du A4 c'est
pas si simple mais plus sympa avec du
coup la menace de manger B7 si jamais tu
bouges le cavalier
mais après ça reste encore jouable hein
c'est chaud tu vois quand tu vois tout
ça bon je sais pas trop longue pour
gagner quoi
mais a priori c'est à peu près égale un
pion qui est un peu faible en C6 mais
j'arrive pas à vraiment
c'est pas autorisé donc ce Caval il peut
reculer mais bon après les tournois sont
quand même active et toi deux c'est pas
simple pas simple et tu comprends
pourquoi
il a pas encore fait il réfléchi mais ça
avait la logique de base mais au final
est-ce que c'est bon c'est une potion
qui est assez égale quand même assez
égal donc bon écoute elle a les blancs
tabattabil elle est noire il fait son il
fait sa partie
et du coup le match de où alors où je la
connais pas du tout figure-toi je la
connais pas du tout
le monde à la vidéo ouais moi je connais
tout le monde mais après
[Musique]
c'est une jeune je sais pas quel âge
elle est là c'est une jeune joueuse
américaine
et du coup non je connais pas toutes les
jeunes choses américaines
alors ça c'est une ligne intéressante
sur le standard en fait avec G3 et H3
tout ça pour essayer d'en empêcher le
cavalier de venir ici en fait de bloquer
l'attaque noir donc moi je veux une fois
une position comme ça dans ma vie
et j'ai gagné avec succès j'avais gagné
très vite en plus contre un jour à 2100
2002 je connaissais pas du tout et lui
non plus je crois en fait c'est marrant
parce que je joue dans dans le tournage
je faisais que le destinienne tout le
temps non
et
j'avais tout gagné que le Benco merci à
chaque fois j'avais eu des gros
problèmes dans l'ouverture comme des
jours à 2000 etc parce que maintenant
c'est une difficile à jouer et là je
vais en 2002 j'en avais marre de le & Co
j'en ai marre de souffrir je dis tiens
je vous laisse indienne mais je
connaissais pas du tout je connaissais
rien on va jouer on va attaquer
trois trucs quoi mais bon je pense que
lui il veut n'importe quelle ligne il
connaissait mieux que moi quoi et je
voulais juste je sais que tu vois
et en fait je pense qu'il a eu peur
d'une préparation il a changé de ligne
alors que moi je connaissais rien de
toute façon donc
j'ai gagné j'avais gagné en 15 coups en
tout cas comme ça j'ai dit du
coup c'est pour moi c'est un Diane et
maintenant je le sens bien
le travail
donc avec un thème dans les Indiens tu
vois c'est plus on prend et ben je
prends une cavalier H4
et du coup c'est assez marrant
le fouet en prise donc la paire de fou
qu'on peut s'aider à manger intéressant
donc écoute moi j'aime bien les Noirs
dans ces positions
je peux rarement tu vois il y a pas de
problème je pense enfin c'est chaud quoi
si je prends là tu peux manger là et je
peux manger là manger là en fait je peux
tout ouvrir et tiens après je vais le
tour en géant j'attaque quoi tu vois
mais c'est encore posé les fous qui
peuvent aussi s'ouvrir à Carrefour
mais de manière générale j'aime bien
avoir les Noirs dans ce dans ces
positions là
qu'est-ce que tu en penses d'ailleurs
toi de cette position Fatou
moi j'aime bien aussi les choses un peu
agressives comme ça en débalancer après
ouais ça souffle des deux côtés en fait
ça peut s'ouvrir des deux côtés le roi
blanc
finalement les patients en sécurité que
ça
avoir mais j'ai je connais pas trop je
connais pas trop du tout ce genre de
position
ouais mais visuellement en fait ça l'air
sympa ça leur actif tu sais c'est la
position en fait tu le roi noir est
assez ouvert mais c'est j'attaque en
fait pour la position alors qu'au final
tu vois chez les Blancs bah écoute
j'ai le C4 c'est important quand même à
prendre en compte
j'ai manqué derrière si la position
comment elle s'ouvre moi elle est
vraiment il est vraiment ouverte quoi
genre cavaler prend un 4 qu'elle va les
prendre à me prendre plus tard il peut y
avoir un faux F5 etc donc pour l'instant
faut F5 non j'aime pas parce que c'est
pas une femme moi j'ai pas cavalier mais
une fois que le cavalier partir ben la
part de fou peut être forte et en plus
autre chose regarde on va imaginer que
le café ici il est parti
une fois que tu manges là et ben s'il
part j'ai fou F5 d'un bouge et E4 enfin
les deux fous vont s'ouvrir quoi tu vois
oups
qui va s'ouvrir en fait et sur le roi
blanc qui va être un petit peu faible tu
vois en fait c'est intéressant en terme
de contre jeu sa position à 4 à 4 j'aime
bien aussi à quatre
ça ça empêche déjà du coup des bons des
B4 de béton mais en plus surtout tu me
menacer souvent à trois et sur un comme
P3 et ben tout sera ouvert j'aurais plus
qu'à à virer lui et à ouvrir un
diagonale pour tomates
parce qu'une fois que ça s'ouvre et ben
le fou il est très fort sur casse
blanche
et donc évidemment je vais jamais
volontairement échanger ce fou contre le
cavalier ça c'est hors de question
parce que quand vraiment c'est fermé
mais de partout et ben finir ce fou
c'est plein de mauvaise pièce quoi tu
regardes F3 direct
[Musique]
je pense qu'il peut presque PRIMOVE
parce qu'en plus ce 4 j'ai même pas oui
bon sur le cadre j'avais même pas qu'il
y a des quatre à cause du plan C5 et là
il y a une tour qui va arriver même même
dame B8 intéresse conjuguer un peu nos
pièces comme ça là ça va être pas mal
on comprend très bien pourquoi tu aimes
les Noirs
[Musique]
par là et là
et si je fais autre chose je fais quoi
tu vois ça
mais bon c'était tu as visuellement ça
l'air très dur pour les noirs pour les
blancs pardon ça la hyper dur donc pas
étonnant
ok est-ce qu'on retourne un petit peu
workawana tu as l'impression que c'est
quand même pas mal liquidé on va
retourner vers votre petit Caravana
je vais vous remettre les petits noms
parce que là regazine il a changé
et où non plus
il va pas
j'arrive pas à écrire ça monte voilà
donc que s'est-il passé
qu'est-ce que tu penses toi cette
position
[Musique]
mettre en avant la paire de fou ouais
mais en fait ça va ça va permettre de
tout échanger
un peu la pression il considère que
peut-être il a un petit plus il est un
peu plus actif
mais bon en vrai je pense que il y a
rien du tout ici c'est assez égal quand
même je pense que ça tourne en rond et
puis ils vont chercher
plutôt espérer un peu tomber sur
sur une tactique un peu voir si l'autre
faute c'est un petit peu ça genre de
position
[Musique]
et puis on prend la
et cette position je pense que bon la
structure qui change bon il a joué comme
ça aussi
[Musique]
je pense qu'il y a pas de souci du tout
pour pour métal et du coup de belle
opération de Mittal s'il arrive à tenir
cette partie contre carvana parce que je
vous rappelle quand même que c'est quand
même
le joueur on va dire le moins fort dans
son équipe
contre le plus fort de l'équipe adverse
donc c'est une telle opération en tout
cas pour
pour l'Indien tu vois parce que là tu
vois par rapport à ce que tu disais
avant en fait d'avoir une féminine à
2500 et non et ben elle peut battre un
peu n'importe qui elle peut se battre tu
vois là autant acheter en 2500 qui
arrive à tenir tête à karwana alors que
ou par exemple contre ergasi on a bien
vu hein
beaucoup plus grand donc c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué
ouais je pense que vraiment
les gens souvent sous-estimes un petit
peu le dernier échiquier alors qu'il est
tellement important
et toi c'est quoi
à combien de combien de cartes parce que
200 300 bon à quel moment ça joue à quel
moment ça joue plus tu vois tout est
possible en plus c'est un jeune
c'est clair c'est clair
mais je pense franchement qu'elle va
avoir une féminaire 2006 c'est donc là
tu vois ce qu'il a fait karwana même si
c'est fou le même couleur etc la gamme
réussit avec avec G5 il a réussi à
bloquer tous les pions sur couleur de
son fou
tu vois et donc ça c'est bien
coopération maintenant est-ce que ça va
suffire je pense que ça va faire nul
mais au moins ici il a une petite
pression comme l'adversaire qui qui
est un petit peu peur peut-être tu vois
on se dit bah ouais regarde
[Musique]
son roi on peut discrètement comme ça il
va se passer
la G4 comme responsable je pense que
prise F4
il faut changer les pions et prise prise
F4 F6 attention que le plan H3
regarde
[Musique]
blanche ça me fait peur et prise par et
là attention
ça peut faire nul quand même mais bon
j'aime bien les couilles ici de
[Musique]
Kawana voilà G4
mais bon maintenant j'ai plus de tout
est bloqué
il va jouer F6 et il va essayer de faire
foulard foulard et aller manger
attention
c'est pas si simple
S
si je fais ça
[Musique]
surtout pas ici je pense
pas bonne pour pour les Noirs
[Musique]
je pense que ça c'est
ça sent et en fait attends je pense
tu attends pas moins de passer
et on voit que tout ça dans la partie du
coup
ouais c'est comme place au direct
priorité mais on a eu deux nuls de
Théodore et de akobiana on ira voir
après ce qui s'est passé rapidement
FC
[Musique]
qui nous a pas mis à jour là
malheureusement
je sais pas ce que c'est toujours
seulement chez moi ça ou c'est chez tout
le monde c'est chez tout le monde
tu as regardé ailleurs non d'accord
merci
à voir
parce que là c'est vrai que
[Musique]
d'ailleurs on nous a demandé dans le
chat ce qu'on pensait de des résultats
de la ronde précédente
je pense que Blitz a dominé dans les
parties franchement c'est vrai qu'il y a
eu pas mal de de
partie qui aurait pu quand même mieux se
dérouler dans ce match
et bon au final il y a un gros score
mais je pense que c'est pas vraiment
c'est pas vraiment du match quoi ça
aurait pu je pense que c'est un match
qui était beaucoup plus serré que ce que
ce que le score en fait nous laisse
entrevoir alors juste une petite seconde
sèche je m'inquiète un petit peu
pourquoi
j'ai encore le score des Blitz et Wailly
tout ça là moi j'ai pas la main dessus
mais tu peux tu peux demander peut-être
ses amis tu es là sur le chat je sais
pas si ça vient lâché maintenant il est
pas là
c'est Sami est là est-ce que
éventuellement
tu peux le dire pour l'instant on va
l'avoir appelé ce qui se passait chez
[Musique]
donc c'était bonsoir bonsoir et
bienvenue bonsoir à toi
du coup c'était la fameuse à lapine
je mange la tienne
donc dame bouge qu'avait je crois c'est
une pollution
à peu près égale ça a tricoté un petit
peu
au final ça échange quand même pas mal
de pièces
pas grand chose pour les blancs c'est
parti
c'est presque les noirs qui jouent pour
gagner en fait
et majorité pour les blancs mais bon
c'est un peu faible ok bon ça change
tout soit bien passé
et ça fait nul ok normal on va dire et
chacun
du coup
on sort on avait vu en stage un peu plus
loin à B3 je crois
[Musique]
ne vous inquiétez pas
intéressant
[Musique]
ok E4 il est déstabilisé le cavalier ici
donc
tout est faible
OK
bon moi je pour l'instant assez serré on
voit que que il y a eu beaucoup de nuls
il y a pas mal de joueurs qui ont tous
2600 hello et Gazi qui a joué contre la
féminine à 1300 et d'eau donc on va
attendre du coup ensemble la ronde 2
donc là
je pense dans quelques instants pendant
ce temps là je vais vous mettre les
caméras pour la rando 2
en espérant que une actualise le petit
le petit truc alors du coup je prends
quoi comme comme apparemment
[Musique]
tu as tout préparé
les blancs du coup normalement
contre
[Musique]
avec
du coup avec les noirs
[Musique]
contre
mital mitter qui a fait une belle partie
[Musique]
en fait que tu vois que c'est bien
d'avoir des jeunes comme ça dans
l'équipe qui sont capables de
plus qu'une minute apparemment vite
t'inquiète pas je suis prêt quasiment
en quatrième
et le 4 du coup c'est
elle est là déjà sauf qu'elle est pas
sur la bonne case
ça va pas tarder
à l'instant
[Musique]
et j'en profite il y en a qui me suivent
sur YouTube
à vous abonner
sur Youtube n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à la chaîne
ça vous coûte rien et ça nous soutient
voilà le slogan de Nathan qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire
j'en suis venu et
du coup oui non c'est vrai qu'on a vu
qu'il y a 29% des viewers Youtube qui
sont pas abonnés à la chaîne alors
vraiment abonnez-vous pour pour être
pour cent qui sont déjà abonnés 71 qui
sont pas abonnés
pour être au courant un peu de ce qui se
passe sur YouTube
je vais écrire un petit peu juste à Samy
[Musique]
pour avoir l'affichage peut-être des
scores
après ne vous inquiétez pas si c'est pas
affiché on va vous le dire à l'oral il y
en a aussi qui sont très attentifs donc
vous serez tenu au courant sans problème
de l'avancée des scores
[Musique]
j'ai pas encore j'ai pas encore ce
affichage
et les choix sont installés
est-ce que cette partie
dans ce corps board j'ai encore le
résultat de
maintenant
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
finalement j'ai eu un petit
imprévu j'ai plein de problèmes dans ma
vie en ce moment t'inquiète pas je vais
revenir je vais revenir
plus fort
[Musique]
j'ai toujours
on me dit bizarre bah oui bizarre
du coup du coup petite pire ou moderne
pour l'instant la pire ça
[Musique]
OK
plein de coups sont possibles ici mais
la marche 3 je pense qu'elle doit être
OK
pour empêcher en fait les prises prises
et fou j'ai 4 avec pression plus tard
sur le pion de 4 développement
on est bien on a le centre
c'est bien gentil quoi
[Musique]
je vais mieux je te laisse ça je te
laisse pas tout
[Musique]
en fait c'est toi qui dois changer la
capture
[Musique]
donc à voir si ça si ça continue
côté de la partie bon les Blancs ont
plus d'espace il y a même si rien n'est
fait là on va juste dans la position
qu'il y a plus d'espace et plus naturel
comme un livre développement
donc c'est tranquille pour les blancs
pour le moment
en fait je viens d'apprendre un truc les
gars je suis vraiment désolé c'était à
moi de le faire
je ne savais pas
je ne le savais pas
je suis en train de le faire de le faire
moi-même
[Musique]
10 minutes plus 2 secondes Arnaud merci
merci de m'encourager à parler en fait
je savais pas hein
[Musique]
on a dit j'ai essayé d'en changer hier
c'est pas encore fait mais je vais
essayer je vais continuer d'essayer j'ai
pas encore de la qualité
je suis désolé j'espère que c'est quand
même
quand même audible
[Musique]
hyper propre même je sais
après normalement on m'entend mais moi
je m'entends bien
très bien
twitch donc
voilà j'ai fait les changements les gens
je suis désolé je ne savais pas que ça
va le faire généralement ce genre de
trucs
et vu qu'on fait un match par jour et
qu'à chaque fois j'ai été le premier
match du coup
du coup voilà je vais
OK
le score vous avez tout qui c'est mis à
jour donc deux et demi 1 et demi du coup
pour les Indiens mgda et du coup là vous
avez le score en dessous des caméras
surtout
le score de la ronde en direct donc du
coup un petit pion qui est parti en
rentrant attention ce petit pion qui
peut un jour être prenable
je suis pas fan de ce petit à trois pour
te dire la vérité Fatou
l'impression qu'un jour il y a moyen
d'aller tu vois un petit coup de
cavalier un petit coup de fou
[Musique]
ok est-ce que mon petit tour Fatou
la deuxième partie
[Musique]
non je la ferai pas
donc tu es autoroute donc à 26 50 moi
j'aime bien la position les blancs tu
vois c'est une position en fait
recomposée
mais quand on pose généralement tu
balances tes pions pour en fait tu veux
aller attaquer le roi adverse etc ce
qu'on n'aime pas du tout c'est que c'est
fermé en fait voilà c'est hyper service
il y a pas de rupture en fait Laurent
Blanc il est hyper sec du coup alors que
là moi je vais faire ça et je vais en
fait me débrouiller pour pour cette
vidéo ouvrir après c'est pas si clair
encore tu vois il y a faut pas tout
bloquer surtout c'est ça puis aussi la
rupture en F4 elle est contrôlée un
milliard de fois par les noirs
et donc bon c'est pas simple encore mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un petit
potentiel quand même ici pour pour les
blancs dans cette partie parce que du
coup est en sécurité et que je peux
jouer un petit peu sur sur ton roi mais
c'est pas grand chose encore une fois
mais c'est un truc qui a l'air assez
cool
qui ont plus facilement rentrer dans le
coin interse donc
c'est ça ça pousse h ça va encore
pousser
non ça
veut pas pousser
OK
tu vois le petit plongé qui a bougé pour
justement aller pousser F et blanche je
pense ou là maintenant ils ont F3 ou F4
qui fait sens voilà en fait il a poussé
H4 pour provoquer G4 pour avoir la
rupture F3 avant c'est un jeu de rupture
en fait et au final après tout ça c'est
les blancs qui vont qui vont pouvoir
attaquer donc là F3 je pense tous les
jours
F3 tous les jours et puis on prend
déjà j'ai pas obligé de manger pour
l'instant encore
je suis pas obligé de manger encore
sauf si je m'en rappelle plus faire un
blogus
voilà courbe qui est descendue très très
bas alors qu'ici c'était quoi le coup
pourquoi la courbe elle est
comme ça en fait
qu'est-ce qui se cache derrière
je comprends pas je veux juste vérifier
par cœur
[Musique]
quand même bizarre
salut les amis
comment vas-tu F4 mais en fait sur F4 je
prends F3 donc pareil et bonne soirée le
tout bonne soirée à toi
c'est marrant Arnaud qui nous dit qu'il
fallait tous garder en pièces
c'est vrai que là j'ai changé de
changer du coup de de
scène donc du coup ben
ils m'ont tout enfin voilà
faut que tu répètes toutes tes scènes
mais c'est vrai que
j'y pensais plus merci à toi en tout cas
pour ton
aide précieuse je remets ça
et du coup Arnaud c'est un petit peu
l'inverse à la première ronde donc c'est
assez marrant
OK
et maintenant je vais aller régler la
scène d'après
ils ont tout prévu je sais franchement
je savais pas que c'était comme ça
et du coup
les pièces noires sont bien ouais
regarde quand même il y a un petit roi
derrière mais
moi c'est une fourchette mais c'est un
peu une fausse fourchette parce que je
viens de le dire il y a le droit
derrière
et on peut encore rien
on peut peut-être aller faire un tour
sur les autres aussi
qui bloque un petit peu tout
et qui permet au noir de
rester un petit peu tranquille
ok je suis bon allez on part sur la sur
la troisième partie
tu vois
[Musique]
akobian du coup
pour cette partie
donc non c'est pas la même hop c'est
celle-là
donc c'est une position
donc là ils ont joué une sorte de
système
hérisson
du système pour moi qui l'inventé
système hérisson donc on voit souvent
contre la Sicilienne d'ailleurs
donc là c'est pas une Sicilienne mais
c'est quand même un système hérisson de
cavaliers comme ça le fou c'est hyper
hyper standard tout ça hyper solide
et en fait on joue si tu veux avec moins
d'espace comme ça mais à un moment donné
si pousse trop vite et ben il peut y
avoir une réaction et ça peut piquer et
c'est pour ça que c'est le hérisson
voilà
donc
plus de choses
ouais mais tu vois que ça peut ça peut
un moment donné il y a souvent des
réactions du style dessin avec des
ouvertures un peu de partout ça peut
être un peu compliqué donc ça reste à
voir après il y a quand même un avantage
d'espace pour les blancs conséquent
donc avoir un peu ce qui va se passer
ici
regardez qui met la pression autant tu
vois un Gazi qui a quand même 7000
contre 3 et qui joue très vite
ça fait sa force aussi c'est beaucoup la
pression après des fois dans les parties
il a un peu moins précis parce que bah
du coup il joue très vite mais c'est
vrai que souvent
ça ça joue quand même
enfin ça fait sa force quoi pour la
caméra de
un petit peu vers le bas j'ai
l'impression c'est quand même de
remonter ou est-ce que c'est lui qui est
juste non c'est lui je peux rien faire
c'est lui qui aimait la caméra trop bas
c'est très intéressant de de pouvoir
prendre une avance autant
que ça c'est bon on va voir ça peut
faire vraiment la différence sur la fin
les deux secondes de rajout c'est c'est
quand même assez maigre ouais deux
secondes de vous parcours c'est c'est
pas grand chose c'est quasiment rien
c'est le temps de prendre la pièce
d'appuyer
et donc voilà oui c'est une belle option
qu'il a pris autant en tout cas et ça
peine ça permet de mettre vraiment la
pression au temps
même dans les coups tu vois en fait ça
fait faire l'adversaire et puis au final
à la fin tu es souvent amené à faire une
gaffe quand tu es malade donc les Noirs
en jeu sans que prendre des cas donc ils
ont ouvert un petit peu ben la clone e
des cases maintenant pour le cavalier tu
vois avec le pion en D4 c'est vrai
qu'ici on verra que le cavalier a du mal
à venir ici donc j'aime bien ce qu'il a
fait à Kobe c'est intéressant tu vois
ici les quatre pions sont barrières
barrière de partout tu vois je fais j'ai
des belles flèches en jouant à 5 je
force B5 donc lui contre le plus et 5
et maintenant je fais donc je le fou et
je fais E5 qui va du coup libérer enfin
enlever ce pion pour du coup libérer la
case c'est 5 pour la cavalier c'est bon
en tant que stratégie c'est intéressant
tu vois il a réussi à enlever les deux
pions ici pour installer un beau
cavalence C5 et donc maintenant tu vois
ce cavalier il a une belle case une
forte case attaque le pion le pion à 4
et donc le Caval est bien placé il a un
délogeable bien sûr j'ai un pion aussi
isolé en dessin
ma faiblesse aussi
la position ouvrir mes fous
j'aime bien les noirs
qui ont des c'est comme facile quand
même pour les bancs de pollution
bon je sais pas si ça va vous donner le
fou hein peut-être fou F5
et ça a l'air quand même facile à jouer
pour les blancs mais
c'est vrai quand même que
j'aime bien avoir les plus actifs j'aime
bien tout ça
a un problème un problème de temps avec
deux buts il a donné le il a donné le
froid
donc
ça c'est quand même une grosse une
grosse décision sur cavalier
on va le voir
la dame ça me paraissait logique pour
enlever le vis-à-vis
et empêcher un peu de dessin sur le
dessin tu fais quoi
c'est quoi le l'ordre de faire je pense
à ça
mais bon
ça a l'air OK pour
pour noir j'ai pas de comprendre
[Musique]
ok
donc encore une fois il occupe 15
novembre c'est bien ça qui est sympa
aussi
de tout casser tout ouvrir moi je mets
bien des cinq
ok est-ce que tu vas voir rapidement le
parti parce que là c'est vrai qu'on a
tanqué là-dessus on va tabataba qu'on
peut aller voir aussi si tu veux ici
[Musique]
avec les Blancs qui a un joueur à plus
de 2006 50
excellent mixeur
je n'aime pas trop il y a un petit peu
tout il y a un petit peu tout en l'air
en fait
il y a quand même des cloches de partout
comment les exploiter
deux pièces sur la même diagonale pour
venir attaquer là-haut j'aime bien
l'idée
juste pour empêcher cavalier 5 je sais
pas si c'est utile
ne serait-ce que pour dire au noir bah
faut jouer quelque chose moi c'est un
coup qui permet en fait de prendre des
cases et de prendre de l'espace
après qu'il y a quelqu'un qui peut
arriver faire attention parce que j'ai
pas trop envie de prendre tu vois c'est
fou prendre les quatre à la fin je peux
pas parler de
la part de fou donc je suis pas sûr
il rentre pas non plus
immédiatement
mais bon
pousser un petit peu ici les Blancs ont
tombé l'avantage encore une fois il y a
le il y a la part de fou et cette
pression constante sur les diagonales
sur les cartes blanches
mais bon il faut encore terminé c'est
pas encore si simple
H4
bon malheureusement il y a froid il y a
d'un problème tout le temps mais dans
l'idée si le pion F2
après qu'il y a des quatre pente ça
pourrait être une idée tu vois
parce que quand je prends en prend et
ben quand tu bouges la dame j'ai plus de
ta marche sans cache avec dommage 7 ça
peut être intéressant
avec H4 tu donnes des idées tu prends de
l'espace tu vas maintenant la position
et donc en fait
qu'est-ce que tu as envie de jouer là
et ben il faut jouer un coup
j'aime pas trop
préférait aller 4
ok prise
taf 5 ou tactique
[Musique]
prise prise de café la plus de 15
qui va monter facilement il y a qui
arrive attention c'est pas facile voilà
voilà voilà
B6 voilà
voilà
j'ai l'impression que ça va
enfin ça va peut-être pas en fait
je mets le four à F5 c'est un peu la
même pause qu'on avait tout à l'heure en
fait
mais pourquoi c'est pas bon je pense
parce qu'en fait du coup après Roland
Roisin roi là
foulard le cavalier plus de 15
voilà c'est perdu non
c'est perdu direct dans une impression
ok comment elle peut mais bon là c'est
trop dur
c'est beaucoup trop dur
c'est beaucoup trop dur l'attentat un
truc quand même
[Musique]
la carie ne bouge pas quand je perds
c'est très dur tu as juste 5
game over
je prends la
et je bouge pas le cavalier ben j'ai
1000 façons de
d'améliorer la position comme genre 5 ou
la qui contrôlera la casse la plus C2
ici
F5 fois aussi alors fou aussi ouais mais
j'aime pas mettre les pions sur casse
blanche raisin juste parce qu'en fait
tu tu me laisserais faire un petit
blocus sur case noire tu vois donc quand
tu as un foot casse blanche tu mets des
pions sur gaz noire c'est plus logique
pour que le faux puisse passer F5 non
j'aime pas du tout
par contre 5
on fait un petit un petit mur avec ça
donc là on reprend il faut F5 c'est
abondant faire ça pour que de fou
contrôle la case ici et maintenant il va
monter le roi peut-être roi important
voilà
belle technique de tabac tabac ici
qui est
manger et ça là il y a déjà trois pions
pour la pièce et puis le roi noir est
trop mal placé c'est complètement perdu
est-ce qu'on part à combien du coup
parce que là du coup ça va je pense qui
est terminé car on a gagné on va aller
voir du coup à combien
à combien qui
qui du coup dans cette position
elle est noire et joue contre
irégasi
ok du coup 3 4 5 3 4 un pion de plus
pour
Erica
tours
si je mange là
[Musique]
revenir un peu sur la sur la nulle de 20
sur la sur le gain de tabataba je trouve
ici intéressant
[Musique]
on parlait de cette finale là
avec ça et je pense que ça va gagner
parce que le roi bouge pas à cause de ça
vous voyez parce que le fou domine
complètement la cavalier donc là un des
seuls coups légaux des noirs
faut 4 bien aussi je pensais pas à ça
je peux même manger et revenir là quoi
c'est la même là
je crois c'est un des premiers mots que
j'ai appris en allemand ma vie
qui veut dire en fait
couper je crois Fatou très bien très
bien
doivent jouer un coup malheureusement et
selon ce qui joue bah ils vont perdre
quelque chose si il bouge le pion bah je
le perds si je bouge surtout moi je le
perds si je bouge le roi ben je perds ça
et si je bouge le cavalier ben je le
perds donc du coup c'est malheureux et
du coup en fait les Blancs ont réussi à
bon après les Noirs ils sont pas SFR et
on se réactif malheureusement c'est
ça ne tient pas du tout ok donc du coup
les Indiens qui ont
fait du coup encore une fois deux et
demi dans ce match on a fait deux et
demi
à 1 et demi deux fois d'affilée ce qui
fait du coup 5 3 dans ce match là on
arrive clairement à la moitié du match
avec deux sets de jouer donc pour les
appareils qui arrivent je vais commencer
à mettre des appareils je vais vous les
donner à l'oral si vous voulez
donc on aura du coup avec les Blancs on
aura un petit
tabac à Bay attends je vais enlever ça
juste
on va voir un tabataba et blanc
contre
Kawana ça y est ça commence
car Wana qui
est chaud
que les grands joueurs commencent
vraiment à s'affronter
et donc là c'est 26 50 entre 2800 c'est
très très fort
ensuite on aura irrigasi du coup avec
les Blancs
et reghazi Théodore irrigazie qui enlève
sa caméra à chaque entre chaque ronde
ensuite on va avoir du coup à Cobian
avec les Blancs
avec les Blancs qui va jouer contre
mital
voilà parfait
et pour la dernière
partie on aura au bout
qui aura du coup
[Musique]
du coup les blancs contre Arica il faut
que je change tout
et ici
voilà
donc chez moi tout à régler j'ai plus
qu'à vous mettre je le petit nom ici
et on sera bon
alors du coup ce sera qu'un avait dit
Caruana
yes alors du coup
c'est un joueur avec qui j'ai joué en
Top 16 donc c'est vraiment un super
joueur et hop je vous enlevez ça je
mettrai des caméras dès que les gens
arrivent voilà un petit peu de privacité
d'intimité c'est ça
et d'ailleurs voilà je suis encore allé
sur une chaîne sur laquelle je t'ai pas
encore allé et du coup et ben Fatou tu
n'as pas averti et ben encore les scores
qui sont qui sont pas bons
j'ai pas vu
je te connais Fatou pas très sympa
[Musique]
une histoire à vous raconter pas drôle
je n'ai pas le temps peut-être
les histoires donc
le soir des fois on faisait des Blitz
avec ta bataille
donc on avait quand même une équipe tu
vois quand même c'est costaud quoi en
Top 16
[Musique]
quand il fallait flagrant mais mais je
l'ai j'ai perdu beaucoup beaucoup
et on a qu'une équipe avec pas mal de
joueurs qui trait etc il part déjà
après il a perdu quand même contre les
petits pragats
il y avait de l'Indien tu vois il y
avait de l'Indien mais quand nous on
joue contre en fait non on n'arrivait
pas c'était trop dur ça c'était le but
oui parce qu'on jouait vraiment
je veux vraiment pour les volets quoi
hop donc voilà par quoi il est pas à
jour
donc moi je suis prêt voilà je vais voir
si les appareils mangent sont sortis
pour la ronde 3 toujours pas on va être
dans l'attente de ses résultats mais oui
il était
ultra
ultra impressionnant c'était il y a
maintenant trois quatre ans il avait
2600 hello déjà
et ouais très sympa il descendait le
matin pour nous aider un petit peu dans
la préparation chacun en fait avec des
parties chacun a des prépas
et ils veulent nous aider pour
checker un peu ce qu'on avait préparé on
lui disait ce qu'on a préparait et ouais
c'est bien ou c'est pas bien voilà
et de son avis et du coup c'était assez
cool toi tu as un grand maître à 2006
qui vient checker un peu de prépa qui
dit
qui disent qu'il en pense et souvent
après il complément enfin complètement
c'est intéressant
de compétition dans laquelle tu
progresses vraiment ce que tu es aussi
très bien entouré moi je pense que
franchement dans cette compétition
clairement en fait
le moment en fait dans la de l'année où
tu travailles plus d'échec quoi parce
que en tout cas ton répertoire tu le
passes dans tous les sens et tu tu check
tout le temps toutes les lignes tu
travailles beaucoup même la tactique etc
et en plus tu es avec des super grands
mains très fin tu vois tu fais pendant
10 jours des échecs tous les jours c'est
vraiment dans le dans une bulle quoi
donc c'est vraiment intéressant c'est
vraiment cool et moi j'ai trop kiffé je
pense que c'est une meilleure expérience
toujours d'échec cet endroit
[Musique]
on paye pas les joueurs et du coup
on a quand même une très bonne équipe
malgré tout pas mal de titres des
maîtres pas mal de mètres
et des maîtres
et on a réussi à monter en Top 16 une
année 30 Top 12 du coup et
malheureusement c'est pas ma tenue on
était un pas grand chose à maintenir
c'est ça à rien c'était il y avait
c'était l'avant dernière ronde un masque
qu'il fallait absolument gagner pour se
maintenir et un match
pas si loin
pas passer loin on perd ce match pas
grand chose et après on
est les premiers non relégués tu vois
rien du tout
il y a plusieurs matchs qu'on aurait pu
ne pas perdre mais bon c'est vrai que
voilà
mais du coup c'est bon parce qu'on avait
on avait ta belle et on avait goût cache
et Prague
et Prague avait très à 14 ans
et avait déjà 2550 tous les deux
au première table c'était hyper
impressionnant et
bon maintenant ils sont plus vieux
maintenant si on monte en Top 16 et
qu'on leur mettait avec nous tu aurais
2007-2017 2017 devant
c'est pas la même
il a pas bougé
une seule de plus
mais bon ok ça c'est parfait important
les
collectionne mais bon en vrai
on passerait
donc là j'ai la partie qui va commencer
si vous voulez je vais vous changer je
vais vous remettre les caméras des
joueurs
d'abeilles et car voilà ça y est ça a
commencé
donc une anglaise avec E3
avec couleur inversée
c'est marrant c'est 3
finalement
c'est ça
et il va j'ai une sorte de ouais une
bonne version de la ressource c'est
rendre avec un temps plus toi c'est
marrant
donc généralement D4 c'est pas trop un
coup qu'on joue généralement après ça
dépend notre position mais c'est pas un
gros conjo générale
parce que
plein de positions par exemple imaginons
si je fais des 4 ma joue un coup
toujours des 5 bah en fait j'ai une
belle case dans ces 5 qui prend
intéressant pour le noir avec un petit
cavalier qui va revenir par là pour
s'installer ici sur la belle case C5 qui
est bloquée
donc là plutôt j'ai envie de dire petit
rock des trois
c'est plus dans l'esprit
après je sais pas
c'est un peu bizarre mais au final ça
c'est une position qu'on peut avoir
couleur inversé avec un temps de plus
pour les blancs
ici dans absolument souvent on jouait il
faut aussi dame desert mais du coup vous
aussi j'ai peur que peut-être des cadres
soit annulées après comme des 4 c'est
généralement pas un bon coup dans ces
positions
avec des quatre et même perdre un temps
tu vois genre je m'en fous derrière pour
empêcher la fourchette et je me dis bah
écoute tu ajoutes des quatre tu ajoutes
des quatre
[Musique]
qui peuvent arriver pour vraiment
ouvrir et donner un peu vie à ce fou eux
deux donc simplifier un pion souvent
donc c'est pas si D5 puis C5 derrière un
sacrifice thématique ou alors peut-être
ces cinq maintenant qui est intéressant
mais là je suis pas sûr
même si c'est cinq puis on prend je vais
manger ici par exemple
il faut ouvrir la position
là il manque un fou le casse noir c'est
chez les Noirs donc même si c'est 5
c'est pas débile dans les getures de
jeux sur 15 mois
plus tard même un jour si j'arrive à
tout ouvrir à mettre un four en A3 un
aussi
donc c'est ça
à voir ce que nous Conques
tabac tabac dans cette partie
une partie intéressante tu vois car
voilà qui ajoute une position normale là
ok mais le cavalier ici il joue à ses
standards assez facile j'ai envie de
dire il joue vite je crois pas la tête
alors on va le voir un petit peu si tu
veux irrégasi voir ce qui se passe chez
lui
qui joue contre théodoro
et donc c'est une position ah mais
attends mais il a fait la même partie
c'était quoi déjà il y a une partie qui
est qui est connue qui a été joué
c'était quand déjà
c'est lors de quel événement
je me demande si c'était pas le tata
style je crois que j'ai commenté avec
Kevin cette fois-ci on a eu un superbe
partie de de je crois que c'était
rapport avec avec les Noirs face
irigazie il a joué un truc un peu
similaire rapport
avec les noirs
[Musique]
chaudes comme ça où il peut attaquer et
puis tu vois ça c'est totalement
irrigasi et je trouve que c'est génial
moi j'aime bien
j'aime bien en fait tu vois le fait que
irrigues il va vraiment
le gain dans dans toutes ces
toutes ces parties ça je trouve ça cool
la mentalité tu vois
il est vraiment comme ça
répétition avec des
[Musique]
son petit plus quoi ouais c'est clair un
grand beauté des échecs
qui testent des choses qui progressent
tu es un Gazi il y a un an il jouait le
il joue le petit mais en challenger et
il a fait 17000 sur 13
tout le monde et il avait 2600 élo voilà
un an après 2730
après il faut encore confirmer parce que
j'imagine qu'il va être champion du
monde et qui est encore beaucoup de
boulot pour tout ça mais en tout cas
très très grosse progression
très très
sérieux d'ailleurs c'est marrant parce
que
carvana en fait ils ont besoin qui
pensaient pouvaient éventuellement enfin
non c'est pas ça c'était parmi la
jeunesse parmi les gens fantastiques tu
vois entre les apps de Rohff
par exemple
lequel vois-tu le plus
passé de 1800 et d'eau
il a dit 100% engagé voilà c'était
carrément
après ça peut arriver sur un tournoi
mais bon ok
en fait surtout des Blitz il est
vraiment vraiment dur à jouer et sur
Internet en plus c'est un monstre
donc là voilà il y a eu tout ré 8 et
puis en prise donc la défendu tourgé un
peu imaginer après il y a F5 qui peut
aussi arriver F5 ça ouvre un petit peu
le roi noir quand même c'est pas
forcément sûr que ce soit un super coup
c'est un carré de B4
pas mal et il veut mettre son cavalier
sur les bonnes cases il veut ouvrir la
colonne des pour ces pièces
c'est un coup un peu curieux car et B4
mais au final on prend un petit peu
faire
il va améliorer le cavalier améliorer la
tour c'est le Nail bienvenue à toi
bienvenue à toi
n'hésitez pas à assurer des questions si
vous voulez
dire des mots doux à Fatou ou si vous
voulez
tout simplement voir des parties en
particulier n'hésitez pas à nous
solliciter
vous avez le droit aussi
je pense pas qu'il soit allé en P4 pour
revenir en C2 pour revenir en dessin que
ça m'a l'air un peu bizarre
j'imagine que l'idée c'est quand même
d'avoir joué enfin deux jeux cavaliers
en 6
et donc on va voir un peu comment ça se
continue
ok est-ce qu'on va le voir un petit peu
la partie de ta copienne on n'a pas
encore vu
à combien ici qui joue du coup
avec les Blancs contre
le jour indien mital
et
il faut nous dire sur quoi
n'hésitez pas aussi enfin tout ce que
l'experts
qu'est-ce qu'on joue là
c'est pas facile de position parce qu'on
a l'impression que tu es blanc peuvent
avoir une belle position avec l'espace
tout ça mais c'est pas facile d'arriver
genre
un truc
et oui
je pense qu'il y a plutôt les blancs qui
poussent ici
peut-être oursin alors pas mal pour
venir défendre en cas de B5 tu vois ma
tour sera ici je pourrais défendre comme
ça et mettre la pression sur le pion C6
qui peut être pas mal ici
et en plus ça ça empêche cavaler ces
trois tu vois
plus jamais de trucs comme ça plus
blague voilà donc c'est un il fallait
juste te demander
et je crois que Neil
il a combien de temps la pendule et ben
c'est écrit ah oui c'est vrai que non
c'est pas écrit
quoi donc les deux joueurs ont aussi 7
minutes
7 minutes sur le je pense que
je me demande si c'est pas parce que
parce que je passe par un autre c'est
moi je vais dans événement et truc là
alors que peut-être qu'il faudrait que
je passe directement par
comment dire
le chaos en live
du coup vous pensez à donner les temps
régulièrement après je peux voir si je
peux
un peu comme prévu
on voit que toutes les pièces blanches
sont à l'aile d'âme donc le roi blanc
est un peu tout seul mais pour le moment
il est pas attaqué par contre il faudra
peut-être se méfier si ça si ça tourne
mais là tout va bien c'est plus les
blancs qui ont les idées en fait
pour empêcher cavalier E5 sûrement
un peu plus facilement rentrer quand
même côté blanc
à voir est-ce que le dessin qui est pas
et pas jouable
c'est jouer
c'est pareil c'est dans la continuité
et les noirs sont pas si les noirs sont
pas si
il défendent vraiment
tout aussi pourquoi pour empêcher le
cavalier de rentrer
on décide
ou peut-être pour pour tous ces 6 un peu
plus tard
bah ça donne moins envie
je pense qu'on est quand même plus plus
à l'aise avec les Blancs
en plus d'idées maintenant faut trouver
les coups
qui vont bien
est-ce que ça marche
je note le fait que le droit de dire que
tu es un génie
j'ai réfléchi après
voilà ok alors du coup ouais non moi
j'aime bien les voir là
mais très solide et du coup on met
cavalier ici on va échanger les pièces
et plus tard ouvrir ici donc on en
parlait de la fameuse attaque l'attaque
[Musique]
le minorité pardon
on va pousser avec un petit pion on a un
contre deux et en fait l'idée c'est de
changer un pion contre un pour avoir ce
petit pion isolé en C6 et pouvoir taper
dessus
on va la voir on va la voir cette petite
faiblesse à taper
donc
du coup s'il prend là j'ai sûrement d'en
prendre et la pression du coup sur
l'option B7 donc c'est l'idée c'est
l'idée donc là pour taper sur C6 soit je
peux manger directement soit je pose
même aussi faire tour c'est 5
doubler
là dessus c'est vraiment
[Musique]
c'est une position assez désagréable à
jouer pour les noirs
je suis un petit peu en retard
un petit retard au temps aussi mais
au moment c'est pas c'est pas dramatique
c'est plus sur du figuier
on aime parler avec des faiblesses
c'est plus harmonieux chez les Blancs
quand même
on peut peut-être faire un tour aller
voir ailleurs
je mets le temps un peu de partout
tu as vu ça
tu me rapproche de plus en plus de te
dire que tu es un génie
j'attends de voir les pendules sur
toutes les scènes pour le dire
je vais me mettre sur la scène que j'ai
oublié de faire
non
ouais alors tu du coup passer la
prochaine partie
on y va donc c'est la partie de
ou contre Arica donc les temps sont bons
aussi Fatou regarde bien comment c'est
incroyable
je vais juste changer le nom ici
les identités ne sont pas les bonnes
F3
bah écoute il y a une tour blanche qui
est le sperme en H5
blanc des Noirs bougent on peut aller on
peut aller la replacer notre tour
peut-être
surtout un tour des cinq qui était
embêtant
donc en fait cette tour elle est mal
placée mais elle est pas encore
attaquable mais sur le long terme si
j'arrive vraiment à tourner 8 améliorer
un peu mes pièces ça défend le pion
dessin qui héberge peut-être aller
manger cette tour et tout rage 3 c'est
moche il faut du temps pour un coincé
quand même
et du coup
donc il y a eu droit à H donc bien sûr
vis-à-vis
[Musique]
de tourger vite c'est quand même que je
veux laisser passer la tour comment je
continue à
parce que tu as un pion arriéré en
arrière c'est un pion en fait qui est en
arrière comme son nom l'indique sur une
colonne semi-ouverte un point qui pourra
plus avancer en arrière par rapport à
options qui sont à côté de lui
n'hésitez pas à demander
[Musique]
du coup bizarre un tour
8 un peu bizarre mais non mais si on
peut imaginer simplement peut-être
pas marcher on échange de pièces je suis
pas tellement sûr parce que bien placés
en défense et tout est changé ça peut
[Musique]
G4 ok
pour des dessins et du coup ça t'oblige
les changer ouais mais dans le collège
qui tombent
il faut voir
tu vas défendre ton petit cœur e et tu
as trop placé en G3 en tout cas tu vas
trop placer
[Musique]
alors oui alors nous malheureusement on
joue pas sortir comme enfin on joue pas
les événements de pièces comme ça on
n'est pas assez fort pour jouer tout ça
enfin tout elle pourrait mais moi non je
suis pas assez fort
et oui donc voilà c'est la stop top
niveau là mais par contre bon tu sais
que ça fait un petit moment que je suis
pas apparu sur sur twitch sur ma chaîne
twitch mais si jamais je pense que
d'ailleurs je vais bientôt reprendre
j'ai failli streamer hier mais très très
bientôt en tout cas je vous promets dès
que j'ai un petit moment je vais revenir
sur twitch et donc photos tu peux me
faire un petit saut s'il te plaît
j'ai du mal à enlever le thé voilà tu
enlèves le thé s'il te plaît
voilà pas de bêtises merci
donc voilà ça c'est le lien pour ma
chaîne si vous voulez venir me voir
quand je suis en ligne donc là du coup
vous étiez Brown tu auras l'occasion de
venir me voir jouer en direct
aux échecs voilà donc j'ai pas leur
niveau à eux là mais mais voilà on fait
on fait ce qu'on peut donc j'espère
pouvoir stream quand même cette semaine
en tout cas ça je vais revenir très très
bientôt mais j'ai plein de trucs à gérer
en ce moment
donc voilà en tout cas n'hésitez pas à
follow la chaîne et aussi pour ceux qui
sont sur Youtube qui nous regardent
depuis YouTube n'hésitez pas aussi à
vous abonner sur YouTube
donc voilà c'est vrai que là il y a on
avait vu un stats il y avait 71 % des
joueurs des gens qui nous regardent sur
Youtube qui étaient pas abonnés à la
chaîne c'est quand même dommage donc
abonnez-vous à la chaîne vraiment ça ne
vous coûte rien
et ça nous soutient merci pour tous les
autres que tu continues
tu peux nous en dire plus
oui j'ai un hellofid à
17,97
elle a la porte des 1800
en fait mais virtuellement la 1800 elle
a gagné des points
de jouer elle passe 1800 euros c'est ça
et voilà moi je suis arrivé moi je suis
à 2300
quelque chose
[Musique]
d'ailleurs je vous ai pas je vous ai pas
atteint j'ai pas comme la vidéo j'ai
promis hier que je le ferai après le
stream mais je la mettre après ce stream
là les gars je vous invite à aller voir
la chaîne stupe échec donc c'est ma
chaîne youtube je vais publier la partie
que j'ai toujours l'interclub
en Espagne je l'ai joué samedi dernier
et j'ai fait une partie hyper jolie où
j'ai fait un sacrifice de dame
positionnel en fait c'est une position
normale et moi j'ai considéré que madame
était pas assez intéressant que ça et
j'ai préféré donner ma dame pour tour
cavalier juste parce que je pensais que
mes pièces feraient plus fortes que la
dame
et c'était le cas donc très content de
la partie que j'ai fait que j'ai fait
bon c'était pas un génie mon adversaire
mais en tout cas
la partie était vraiment très sympa donc
sur la publier quand même voilà c'est ça
non mais en vrai c'était marrant parce
que j'ai fait une photo de calcul à la
base pour en arriver là il faut le dire
chez blender et du coup dans mon blender
et ben je pensais être en grosse
difficulté et pour vous dire la vérité
j'ai pas vu mieux que sacrifier madame
mais en fait je trouve que si il mange
madame comme il l'a fait et ben il est
perdant et du coup en fait c'était un
semi trap tu vois
et du coup j'ai réussi à bien la voir
voilà c'est gagnant pour les marins 3
contre 3 mais les pions sont tous
isolés donc en fait ça
depuis on passe
après B3 plus que deux prises et on
pousse on pousse on pousse alors que lui
va nulle part lui va nulle part vous
voyez
la partie belle technique en tout cas
dans cette finale alors qu'on voit que
karwana abattu tabac Tabeille on ira
voir la partie après quand on aura fini
la ronde on va plutôt donner priorité au
direct est-ce qu'on verrait pas sur une
partie on va devoir rapidement que tu
vas combien qui ont l'air de de d'être
plutôt proche de finir avec une finale
de Tours avec un pion de plus pour
akobial
le long des joueurs ici là-haut c'est
pas à Kiara Akira c'est pas harika c'est
ici mital
et la dernière partie de la troisième
ronde c'est ça
et là ça devient quand même
un peu nécessaire pour pour Saint-Louis
de
gagner et attention parce que le score
c'est 7 4 il reste deux parties en jeu
et en cas de en cas de de 8 et demi et
ben le match est directement terminé
donc si jamais
les Indiens marquent deux parties on
voit que hiragazi a gagné aussi ça fait
mais bon je crois qu'ici mital
gardera pas
donc si j'ai pas de bêtises on s'est
arrêté tout à l'heure c'était combien le
score c'était
actualisé
donc cette pollution alors avec gagnante
on va la jauge
on pousse exactement la même position
c'est marrant
une partie que j'ai joué à
Saint-Sébastien la même position
exactement je suis sûr que c'est
[Musique]
le temps côté
noir il y a plus de temps du tout il y a
plus de temps alors attends
je vais te la montrer la partie
toujours dans quel club je trouve tu
peux le mettre au pluriel je pense la
question parce que enfin plusieurs clubs
[Musique]
avec le foot ben vous avez un simple
clope voilà
moi j'ai plusieurs clubs là je joue
actuellement dans trois clubs
trois clubs en même temps donc j'ai un
club en France
il y a pas de souci donc j'ai un club en
France donc c'est qu'un échec j'ai un
club en
Belgique c'est que le club de Wavre et
j'ai aussi un club aux Canaries donc en
Espagne du coup c'est les Canaries là où
j'habite pour l'instant
donc voilà donc du coup 7 5 du coup pour
les pour les
Indiens là il y a eu deux dans ce match
alors rapidement parce que c'est passé
à peu près par là il y avait eu des 4 il
y a eu ces cinq tu vois on en a parlé de
ce coup d'ailleurs c'est ici qu'on a
parlé c'est 5 le coup de tour pour
ouvrir les cases noires ce qui est
logique on a la part de fou on peut
ouvrir les colonnes
prise prise
et des planches
au final ça me solide pour les pour les
Noirs donc là c'est vite là pour voir un
peu ce qui s'est passé le roi et plutôt
safe il y a quand même un problème sur
avec ta marche je crois qu'il peut
arriver attention et après j'ai quatre
maintenant il y a un problème sur la
case F4 donc avec un bon dire sur la
belle case F4
du mal vraiment
grosse partie de carbone à un qui a mis
la pression qu'avait les B5 pour
terminer ça très joli cavalier V5 si je
prends il y a d'arme du coup je prends
je perds à la respire ces quatre
et je perds tout après ça évidemment
donc parce que je menace dame F1 échec
et mat et aussi d'un point F3 et chaque
email pas tout défendre avec le blanc en
même temps c'est totalement impossible
grosse partie de carbone franchement
il juste rapidement on s'est arrêté où
on s'arrêtait un cavalier
attends un peu
[Musique]
ici donc il a joué c'est qu'il est
revenu en dessin d'accord
[Musique]
qui permet de prendre de l'espace et
chasser la dame mais au final la dame
bouge et les noirs sont un petit peu
ouvert quand même
pour le pion F5 du coup c'est la partie
pour des huit tours G1 mais Laurent en
sécurité la tour ici tu vois comment
elle a réussi à attaquer c'est c'est ouf
comment il place ses pièces
j'adore
jolie sur cavalier
en fait
comment
il faut voir s'il y a pas échec et dame
là
qui peut être quasiment matin
on vient de le voir elle est montée
[Musique]
et en fait au final
c'est compliqué cette histoire pour la
souffrance
il y a pas mal
c'est la place de jouer
pour ces deux enfin
c'est hyper compliqué quoi hyper
compliqué et là du coup en jouant juste
ici
à la place
si tu prends
qui va
[Musique]
Materi qui s'appelle Matt des Arabes
les Noirs faire des trucs et si les
choses
les échecs et les forces en priorité
ok belle
à combien il a gagné la finale que
d'ailleurs il faut que je recherche
alors avant de rechercher la finale
Fatou je vais mettre la caméra
en fait c'est en termes de ronde il y a
4 ans là on va entamer la quatrième et
donc 4.4 et là on voit qu'il y a deux
points d'avance pour pour les Indiens
donc en fait
si les 600 lui rattrape pas dans la
dernière ronde bah c'est gagné pour les
Indiens
et bonsoir bonsoir coco est-ce qu'il y a
des Français qui joue ce soir les
Français ont joué
avant à 16h30 je crois
donc ils viennent de quand ils ont
terminé et ils ont perdu les Français
du coup faudra voir
peut-être en replay
en replay mais c'était pas sur sur Just
Cause
si tu veux pour voir les Français mais
du coup j'ai un peu soutenait le
résultat donc c'est un petit peu triste
alors on dit on dit qu'ils ont perdu on
dit pas combien
donc ça peut-être un petit peu de
suspense tu vas aller voir coco
[Musique]
il y a deux points d'avance pour les
Indiens donc là ce que les Américains
mettent du coup trois-1 minimum 3 1
3 minimum
la Mittal est blanc dans la partie
3 ça va être compliqué et là c'est sur
la dernière ronde normalement c'est le
meilleur d'une équipe contre le meilleur
de l'autre le deuxième compte le
deuxième etc donc normalement c'est les
parties les plus les plus équilibrées
sur la dernière le dernier match donc
faut finir de démontrer à niveau égal
plus ou moins égal qui va le mieux s'en
sortir
évident l'équipe de stuff et bien en
tête après c'est rattrapable donc
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
c'est faisable c'est franchement
faisable
il y a eu quoi il y a eu
il y a eu
greachuk mvl
Catherineau au 3 et
Alexandre Bacro au 4
[Musique]
Sébastien
ça marche est-ce que tu as réglé aussi
les caméras avec les noms
parce que j'ai oublié de
valider
par contre la partie
je la trouvais
elle c'est intéressant aussi le fait de
devoir faire vraiment trois points
normalement Saint-Louis va jouer
plus agressif
ça peut être marrant à regarder plus
marrant que que les nuls de la première
ronde en fait plus
peut-être fatigué
salut
à tous
j'ai pas la partie malheureusement je
cherche et je crois que c'est la ronde 2
et là j'ai plus à partir de 3
c'est parti que j'ai rangé sur
l'ordinateur
quelque part et que du coup je la
retrouve et du coup j'ai un peu
salut rayanou
issement
je suis triste mais je sais que je
finirai par la voir
[Musique]
là ça a commencé ok donc on a du coup
une sorte de slave d'échange joué par
karwana donc les gens c'est une ligne
qui est très
plate très tranquille pour les blancs
le blanc qui vont essayer de jouer une
partie tranquille sans trop de
ça
donc
après c'est un je trouve que c'est un
choix un peu un peu bizarre de la part
de carbonade de jouer ça avec les Blancs
sachant qu'il est un petit peu en
mustwin et
du coup pour gagner une partie est quand
même plus
intéressant que de jouer à une pollution
quasiment symétrique
normalement on devrait avoir des parties
un peu plus épiques
parce qu'ils doivent gagner
dans quelque chose avait montré vraiment
s'ennuie sur cette ronde
technique qui va réussir à prendre le
dessus sur sur eagasi vu que c'est quand
même un meilleur joueur d'échec je pense
mais voilà
il va l'avoir à l'expérience
salut le copac et Saint-Louis son
sponsorisés par THINKY non en tout cas
[Musique]
en fait c'est pas simple de faire jouer
ce soir si tu veux parce que sommeil il
a beaucoup de dents
et
donc c'est bien beau de faire jokerwana
mais au final je vous rappelle que par
rapport à la compression d'équipe on
veut pas dépasser les 25-50 on est là en
fait il faut être entre
24 et 25 50 c'est ça
en fait non enfin tu fais ce que tu veux
mais
un jour à plus de 1700 et 2700 euros en
dessous il a son environnement et
[Musique]
oui c'est 2014 et une joueuse à
2350 et plus reste de 1350 ce qui veut
dire en fait que là vous avez Caruana il
a de 1781 comme ça il compte comme un
2700 et pareil pour ce pareil pour tout
ça et du coup si vous avez plein de
joueurs hyper fort comme carolanade
comme sec etc et ben d'ailleurs il faut
que vous ayez
la marine néo qui va avec quoi quand tu
mets de 2700 c'est pas simple après je
sais pas si là
est-ce que s'ils avaient
pas tu enlèves un des joueurs tu mets de
1700 à la place tu enlèves par exemple
je sais pas moi à combien tu mets soit à
la place à ce que la moyenne et l'eau ça
tient
[Musique]
ici tout à l'heure
ça ferait une 574 tu vois
donc c'est trop
c'est trop long
il faut mettre un autre
et donc en fait c'est compliqué pour
quand même par rapport au Moyen-Orient
tu peux pas mettre n'importe qui donc
mettre sauce c'est cool mais après sur
il faut être fort devant sans être trop
faible derrière parce que par exemple
imaginons si je prends saut et ben je
dois prendre un 2500 ou 3 mais en 253
fera peut-être moins de points qu'un
2006 en gros tu préfères avoir un 2007
et un 2005 on va voir de 2006
donc du coup c'est intéressant de voir
un peu les les équipes tout ça par
contre ce qui est intéressant
d'avoir une féminine à 2550 2006 c'est
intéressant parce que
elle est ramené à 23 ans donc du coup tu
en as une à 2005 comme là tout à l'heure
on avait chez Blitz on avait
aussi Joe and Jones champion du monde et
ben en fait elle compte comme un 2350 et
du coup c'est intéressant en fait
d'avoir une comme ça
et voilà quoi
donc c'est cool
et des fois c'est cool aussi d'avoir une
famille dans un petit peu moins forte
pour pouvoir mettre plus de gros devant
en fait ça dépend vraiment de la compo
qu'on dit toujours je pense tu vois ça
dépend vraiment de la configuration je
pense de l'équipe en face
en tout cas
ce journal oui il y a un gros tendance
en ce moment etc mais bon du coup bah
oui il est pas dispo quoi
j'en ai vraiment des stratégies
après on voit que ça joue pas non plus
un grand chose
le premier match et Dominguez il a pas
été bon Dominguez il a il a fait je
crois que les nuls et une défaite je
crois qu'il a fait sur 4 c'est comme ça
donc bon tu vois en fait si en plus en
première échiquier en échec et qu'il est
pas en forme bah en fait c'est dur quoi
donc c'est un dans l'équipe qui joue pas
bien c'est hyper dur parce qu'il part
pas beaucoup de points et surtout un peu
le maillon faible de l'équipe quoi donc
du coup
quand tu as 45 dans ton équipe Carson
qui peut te mettre 4 sur 4 quand tu veux
enfin quand il veut non mais
mais ils peuvent être 4 sur 4 quoi bah
c'est vraiment intéressant quoi parce
que je vous rappelle pour gagner le
match il faut faire 8 points et demi
qui fait déjà 4 tu vois c'est pas mal
après ils sont trois pour faire quatre
points derrière ça va quoi
donc du coup tu as une locomotive peu
importe où tu l'as 1 2 3 4e échelle
c'est intéressant
ok donc ça c'est une partie bon il se
passe pas grand chose
on va aller voir un peu ce qui se passe
chez Théodore
alors théodoro que fais-tu du coup
tabac d'abeille et du coup on va changer
aussi le nom
notre ami on va
théodoro qui joue contre tabac tabac
c'est intéressant qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé là
qui a eu ces 5
prise
qui est par défaut
donc c'est un coup qu'il faut pas faire
à la maison ça dégâts si le félins parce
que c'est un spécialiste qui sait ce
qu'il fait mais généralement donné le
foot en keto pour un cavalier qui ira
demander à personne généralement c'est
une mauvaise idée
il y a le trou noir chez les blancs en
moins quand la dame est partie on n'a
pas perdu tout d'attaque
là ce qui se dit en fait c'est qu'après
pu on prend bah le fond en haut 3 il est
pas forcément si bon que ça et du coup
les pions plus tard seront faibles et il
va les manger en fait c'est pareil qui
prend en donnant le flou ce qui est
intéressant du coup mais du coup
Théodore je mange là
et du coup si tu enfin tu es Chloé tu
vois tu as ça en prise et c'est
compliqué et tu manges ici bah le
tourbéante et c'est compliqué donc il y
a eu ça ça
et là ici il y a pas eu tout reprend
mais
à cause de sûrement d'âme C8 qui devait
gagner une pièce
donc attaque le fou
vous voyez dame C8 attaque double
maintenant
et du coup l'idée c'est que sur
ça il y a eu 5 exactement
je pense que j'ai de combler cette parce
que maintenant il y a sans prise c'est
pas comme tout à l'heure
encore
il faut bouger la tour il y a un peu de
jeu quoi je comprends
mais ok j'ai l'impression quand même que
c'est bizarre ce que font les blancs et
que les Noirs ici peuvent pas être moins
bien
c'est mon ressenti par rapport à tout
mais bien d'aller taper des avec les
Blancs après si tu regardes des cours
réellement
moi j'aime bien quand même les blancs
c'est chaud et là si je joue pas E5 bah
en fait pour un coup ben je vais jouer
je sais pas alors j'ai même par exemple
puis 5 même tu vois je mets un petit
pion enfin beau cavalier ici je bloque
tout et au final tes pièces sont pas
très bonnes quoi c'est une idée aussi
qui peut y avoir
est-ce que je peux manger là ou pas
[Musique]
tous les sens ça vaut vraiment prendre
mon temps
à 5 je prends échec et à la fin je
prends ici
mais bon ici il y a un pion de plus pour
les noirs
mais je vais
manger
manger là et manger là
cette position elle est pas si simple
même si l'âge tu prends là
tourne je me suis rendu compte en jouant
mais par contre je peux je découvre DS5
oui mais du coup
mais ça joue alors que là
je mange là je fais ça bah là je vais
manger F7 tu prends pas des fois
donc là du coup je peux même je pour
gagner que les Blancs une fois que je
mange là bah attention j'ai quand même
des découvertes
améliorations donc c'est la partie la
partie et bon ça va faire nul ça là on
va assister à une belle nulle de combat
des deux joueurs vont avoir un petit peu
s il faut pas des nuls normalement et
ouais mais bon c'est ce qu'on peut
[Musique]
qui joue contre akobian
peut se transformer en Master Class
positionnel
[Musique]
du coup non ça c'est une pollution de
type
Benoni inversé
qui vient de l'ouverture pretty avec les
Blancs
donc maintenant en plus d'espace au
centre mais moi j'ai plus d'espace de ce
côté là il y a une manœuvre typique qui
est
B4 pour venir après sur cette PLK voilà
tu vois
contrôler toutes ces cases là une fois
que tu joues B6 est ouvert donc il va
bien sûr cavaler B4 là qui a l'air assez
évident tu vois un cavalier de Pékin tu
étais très très logique
lui aussi en prise donc c'est pas si
facile maintenant
[Musique]
je peux tu vas accompagner mon petit fou
avec mon pur là c'est intéressant mais
pas encore ça il va pas manger ça et
peut-être que mon cavalier sert à rien
en fait
à surveiller
[Musique]
mais là il faut calculer sur ça genre ça
ça là je gagne un pion on a l'impression
par contre même si qu'est-ce qu'il y a
pas qu'à aller prendre les trois
et là c'est compliqué
très compliqué si je prends la tu prends
la
je bouffe tout
je pense que
c'est super marché tu prends tout ce que
tu veux
l'expression
tu vois je prends il prend je prends il
prend chacun son côté
[Musique]
je ne sais pas j'ai 4 cavaliers H4 ouais
aussi
mais je pense quand même tu as même à la
longue même si un jour ça se passe mal
pour les Noirs niveau du matériel et que
je dois sacrifier une qualité et quand
même de bien passé au final à la fin tu
ferais jusqu'à maillé ici je pousserais
des pions malgré tout c'est dur pour les
pour les blancs je pense que je peux pas
donner plus en fait c'est vital
c'est pas mital c'est vital
ça faisait longtemps à mes blagues que
tu les écoutais pas Fatou je sens que
c'était mon cœur
ah c'est bon vraiment tu te rapproches
du génie 7
attention
j'y pensais bon c'est compliqué
c'est une position à trois résultats si
jamais je me prends le 4 je vais
souffrir si vraiment j'arrive à bien
contenir la poussée E4 et à bien je
solide et ben ça peut être ça peut être
vraiment
vraiment très très bien pour les blancs
avec plein de cases partout vous voyez
mais pas sûr pas simple ok la dernière
vital
avec
[Musique]
les Noirs les Blancs pardon contre vous
contre vous alors du coup qu'est-ce qui
se passe là en cette partie
c'est compliqué qui a tout perdu non
ouais mais bon c'est dur elle vraiment
[Musique]
le densité très forte
un plus gros vélo c'est ça donc aux
autres tables
en fait en face
du coup c'est hyper dur un peu
j'aime bien cette position pour les
pour les blancs
en plus
il y a même du foie H6 rigolo qui peut
arriver un jour il faut prendre la
fourchette c'est un thème qui arrive
souvent dans ses positions
pour échanger le foucassement
il faut le dire que je suis un génie
enfin ça fait une heure que je te
propose de me le dire ok ok mais les
Indiens connaissent leur position
Dame des deux et là du coup bah tu vois
généralement pour faire l'idée on fait
fou des deux enfin fous aux trois
quelque part damla il faut agir là il
l'a fait en deux en fait tu vois qu'elle
a gagné un temps c'est beau
et je commence un petit peu à peu près
juste
que se passe-t-il à tout
et une fourchette d'accord c'est bon
j'ai vu la fourchette
non je m'en fous je fais ça
parce que là on défend tout et F3 et au
final les blancs écoutent ils ont
acceptés
le piote encaissé
et ça a l'air plutôt bien pour les pour
les blancs
[Musique]
même à la limite je travaille 3 cavalier
2 enlever ce cavalier
tu vois
ça va bien
oui
[Musique]
donc là du coup il y a une nulle entre
théodoro et état bataille et donc du
coup il faut plus qu'un petit point pour
les
pour les les indiens pour gagner ce
match donc sur les trois parties qui
restent Carrefour un point et au moins
un match nul pour
[Musique]
de faire de faire un nul en tout cas
ici cette position elle a l'air gagnante
pour les blancs mais bon il y a pas
beaucoup de temps la pendule il peut se
passer encore des choses et du coup chez
Areca c'était quoi déjà Rica
ou les blancs sont quand même mieux mais
c'est chaud là tu vois il y a le plus
gros chien qui a été mangé et donc du
coup c'est vrai que ça nous il y a plus
qu'un pion ici donc il va être moche
batiplier parce que du coup arrêtez à la
3 minutes contre 30 secondes un pion de
plus une très bonne position
[Musique]
il y a un autre de moins donc ça va
risque de perdre aussi et carwana qui
bancaire
[Musique]
tu vois il y a quand même une grosse
pression avec le cavalier qui est bien
meilleur que le fou les trous sont case
noirs le rock est faible et donc il y a
une pression je pense que karwana peut
clairement la gagner
mais c'est malheureusement peut-être le
seul échiquier ou vraiment
[Musique]
et ben les Indiens peuvent remporter la
partie je vais vous mettre si vous
voulez la caméra sur sur carwana ici
je vous mets le nom des joueurs aussi
vous méritez
car wanna ici
et du coup du coup cette h6 il y a un
match du couloir attention je mange
comme ça je vais venir ici pour mater tu
manges la dame je viendrai
il y a au moins dans mes buts que la fin
au moins ça
mais je l'aime d'un point et cavaler
dans
j'ai plus qu'à pousser mon pion
d'abord
et fin de la partie on va les joueurs
qui ont quitté la salle
qui ont quitté du coup le zoom
on va changer de partie du coup si je
pars chez Tabata Bay salut
c'est l'âge après je te donne confondu
un joueur qui a 26 50
c'est pas mal
tu as une 35 avec les Blancs contre 10
secondes avec une position écrasante
quand même tu vois il y a un pion de
plus et en plus du pion de plus et ben
il y a des il y a une pression de
partout quoi
donc là je peux pas manger ici grâce
est-ce que j'ai 5 puis on prend les h6
il mange de la dame ok elle mange de là
et il faut prendre S5 qui prend là
donc ça se barre chez les marques à main
comme ça
[Musique]
ici attention en prise
tu vas manger là mais je mangerai ici
j'ai quand même
ce qui peut être très très fort
[Musique]
bon courage
donc lui il tente le matin regardez tac
tac on sent il peut faire la souffle
mais ça marchera pas
non plus oui
je prends la
défendre tomber trois c'est très bien
aussi prise je prends la
et après l'échange
j'ai plus qu'à booster
franchement les Indiens hyper hyper
impressionnant dans ce match
on voit que c'est un peu la féminine qui
fait la différence justement comme tu
l'expliquais à chaque fois le fait de
pouvoir tourner c'est mon truc en fait
[Musique]
du jeu je trouve au noir
mais il a un pion passé
en fait il a raison
il tente donc là il revend F5 dommage 7
mais ici qui s'en fout parce qu'on va du
coup comme le fou contre toute la
diagonale et ben il y aura jamais
d'échec avec la tour en fait
donc il défend il fait chèque tour à
deux attaque le fou s'il fou bouge je
paierai 2 et là c'est compliqué donc il
y aura enfin et en fait ça répète pas le
choix ça fait nul bonne partie en tout
cas qui a bien tenu et pour du coup la
dernière partie je vous enlever du coup
les caméras les gens s'en vont et ben on
s'est arrêté par là il y avait eu tout
ça c'est un tricoter un petit peu
[Musique]
l'échange des pièces a eu lieu voilà on
perd les pions H4 mais j'ai tellement de
jeux tu vois que le roi noir est faible
en tout cas plus que le roi blanc dame
et c'est beau ou trop difficile
trop difficile donc du coup si on voit
un petit peu les matchs attendent comme
ça par match du coup je pense que si je
fais ça évidemment je vais pas préparer
cette scène petite seconde je vais juste
vous vous changez ça
parce que voilà c'est ça
petite secondaire
avant mais du coup tout marche très bien
et du coup je vais vous mettre du coup
le score des joueurs
le score des joueurs dans ce match donc
du coup on a karwana qui a fait trois
points et demi sur 4 monstrueux
[Musique]
Carona qui a montré un petit peu qui il
était dans ce tournoi
donc 3 et demi face en plus il a fait
nul contre contre Mittal tu vois le
dernier héros
théodoro 1 an et demi
à combien un point et demi et ou qui a
fait du coup
zéro après 0 tu vois c'est par honteux
quand tu vois en face les vélos enfin tu
vois tu as 2500 à 2500
2650-2017
c'est normal tu vois
mais c'est difficile je trouve pour
un 2300 pas comme ça tu vois la féminine
pour moi c'est vraiment un
sachant que elle à 22,98 elle compte que
module 1300
mais tu prends une mine qui a rupture
comme Arica qui a 2500 hello elle elle
compte comme une 23,50 en fait harika
elle a caséne la même valeur si tu veux
que
en terme de moyenne tu vois pourtant
elle à 2500 € et la fille donc tu vois
si tu regardes vraiment deux points et
demi ou son passé juste enlève les
points de Rica bah on est là en fait
tu vois
les centaines des lots d'écart pour la
différence parce qu'il y a eu trois
points de regazzi contre trois et demi
deux contrats et demi et deux contre un
ennemis de ta copienne et en fait ben
tout se joue en fait souvent après
chacun en fait donc c'est c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué donc en tout
cas gros gros match des Indiens qui sont
toujours très très dangereux avec un
Gazi qui est hyper dangereux en tête
d'affiche donc voilà bah écoute Fatou
nous oups ta caméra qui n'est pas pas
mis en place j'ai voulu faire la la
belle
[Musique]
je suis désolé on va revenir du coup sur
l'autre j'ai la flemme de la changer
je voulais je voulais du coup terminer
le stream sur une belle sur une belle
scène mais vous l'aurez pas ici du coup
donc merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir
accompagné pour ce stream merci à
Chester d'arriver au dernier moment et
et du coup bah écoute Fatou à très
bientôt en tout cas sur chaise comme
merci à toi merci aussi à tous le chat
de nous avoir suivi de m'accompagner
pendant ce beau match
merci à toi pour l'accueil et pareil par
le chat ce fut un plaisir un honneur et
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner sur Youtube
qui mot de la fin comme pour ceux qui
sont sur sur twitch un petit follow ça
coûte rien et vous serez toujours averti
quand on sera en ligne et pareil pour
YouTube un petit un petit abonnement
c'est gratuit et puis toujours aussi
averti quand on prendra des nouvelles
vidéos etc en tout cas c'est intéressant
merci à tous et je vous dis à très
bientôt ciao ciao bonne soirée